welcome back Prince Charles will sell
out his stool to save the Commonwealth
during a trip to Rwanda assisting that
members are better and stronger together
got his work cut out though with many
countries poised to potentially become
full republics when the prince becomes
king having maintained their links to
the royal family in some cases out of
respect to the queen Australia and
Jamaica are among those countries to
potentially one day want to cut their
ties so all the Commonwealth crumble
when Charles does become the Monarch I'm
joined by tonight's beers back talk to
the contributor Esther cracker an author
Julie bentle welcome to both of you
thank you so Julie I know you're a
massive fan of the Royals
you're not you don't really believe in
it right you don't you don't think we
should have a monarchy and so de facto
the Commonwealth Falls does it I'm a
republican
um I respect that the queen works
extremely hard and she didn't really
have much choice in her role so I'm not
rabid but no I think that the
Commonwealth should die when she dies
and I think that for many countries and
countries I visited Kenya Uganda and
others for them it's only really the
elite that think that the Commonwealth
is worthy of any attention and whereas
other people especially those that live
in poverty and hardship they think that
ties with nato in the UN are probably
far better far better serve them than
the Commonwealth Minister I've been in
Australia recently where they've had you
know a bit of republicanism in the air
but I definitely got the feeling they're
quite a way away from wanting to sever
their links but a lot of it is pegged to
the queen tremendous respect for this
unique World figure really no one's
quite sure what's going to happen when
she is sadly no longer with us we're not
sure when that will be obviously but
there is a lot of sort of precariousness
around the monarchy and the Commonwealth
all of it what do you think I think it's
quite a Pity that you know the
Commonwealth has now just become
synonymous with the queen as opposed to
the royal family
um and you know I actually dispute the
idea that it's just you know amongst the
countries that you were mentioning it's
just an elitist idea actually if you
think about the Commonwealth and the
potential of the Commonwealth it gives a
lot of these countries a lot of
visibility so if you imagine you're a
small African country in the middle of
nowhere you know petitioning the UN to
help solve a political dispute or
anything like that doesn't really get
the attention of these large
organizations but you can have direct
access to countries like India Canada
the UK and they are actually far more
useful in solving these sort of issues
than you know big organizations I agree
with you for small countries that
normally would not got the attention of
the u.net I mean obviously we haven't
seen the realization of that yet but
there's so much potential with this
organization post-brexit to actually
deepen its ties with the Commonwealth I
think one of the issues I have with
people that took down on the
Commonwealth is really understanding
Britain's place post-brexit and in the
21st century as it is now it's not that
you know Britain that came out of the
second World War the British Empire all
that everything's evolved and the royal
family will evolve with that but we also
have to understand the Commonwealth's
role in that there's so many
opportunities to to expand Britain's you
know touch around the world and the
values that Britain had um
um also did but I think it's so sad I
could feel with the Platinum Jubilee it
was a uniquely British Asian and when
you travel the world like I've done a
lot you know there's a lot of people
envious of what we have here this royal
family this Pomp and pageantry you know
people say what's the point of view I
said well actually that's the point of
it it's not it's something uniquely
British it pays for itself through
tourism most of the time that's true
though well it is pretty true I think it
pays some businesses through tourism I
don't think it goes directly to the
people whereas from the people are our
uh tax goes directly to the royal family
didn't you feel a little twinge of
patriotic further I I saw all the flags
waving and I don't have an issue with
patriotism I think that you know we
should be proud of the things that we're
good at doing and that we should be
proud of the things that we that we
should be proud of but I don't think we
have to see that through the lens of a
privileged family that is it's it's
obscene when you think about the
homelessness and people using food banks
and you see the vast wealth and
privilege of a family that we're
supposed to dot
much more than that well they do they do
an awful lot of work for Charities up
and down the country they do a huge
number of public engages things which
will bore me rigid they're doing them
every day all day the royal family is a
lot more than just a privileged family I
completely agree with you yes they are a
privileged family but there are a lot
more than that and I think a lot more is
at stake than just saying let's get rid
of this privileged family let's get rid
of the you know the Commonwealth and all
of these things I feel like and you know
it's not just
um countries that were in the British
Empire that part of you know the
Commonwealth there's Rwanda obviously
um
I've got to jump in here very quick test
apparently there's a flamingo test where
if you can balance on your leg for 10
seconds or more you've got a longer life
ahead of you I'm going to spare you
because you've already said everything
you don't want to do absolutely get up
here okay let's do this right up you go
on one foot we've got 20 seconds I'm in
heels I'm gonna go that's to go okay one
two three four five six seven eight nine
said you were wobbling I am Rock Solid
I'm gonna live forever you have the
kraku have got problems and you Julie
very sensible that's it so my lovely
panel thank you very much whatever
you're up to keep it unsensitive